[Music]
we're hoping to expect more of and
actually we're expecting more we're not
hoping to we do expect more out of him
it's not really been able to live up to
it so far in the pro league actually got
really really depressed when
i noticed everyone was like saying mean
stuff about me that's actually one of
the reasons why like i stopped playing
counter-strike entirely
tens really feels like a
once-in-a-lifetime type player
oh boys let's go we got
valerian finally oh man all of them lose
his face and he's getting a jumping one
as well
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it now it's on
land now it's international
will you live up to the hype commercial
in its tents
don't count it out oh my gosh dude don't
count it out
but still playing pivot jumping in
clears up one get around the corner
sentinels win a fifth by the skin of
their teeth
and what is tens doing running a blog
getting free
the team flash magnum's in the smokies
oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels are the masters to
reykjavik champions this
is the best team i've ever played on
tyson tens no is anything
but ordinary after being introduced to
counter-strike by his uncle at a young
age
ten spent his teenage years terrorizing
the north american fpl scene
he was a young prodigy with inhuman aim
and reaction time
and before long one of na's most
prestigious cs go teams came knocking
cloud9 the team's igl at the time dapps
decided to take
a chance on tens adding the then 17 year
old to cloud9's newly formed roster
something that the young canadian could
only have dreamed of
actually i think i think c9 is probably
the best org he could have signed with
like when in terms of counter-strike in
terms of like
fan base in terms of like legacy like
there's just so much
merit that comes with signing with c9
that's just insane
by then tens had already amassed quite
the following on twitch with his
flashy highlight reel of clips he was a
clip
machine so when he joined cloud9
there was a lot of buzz but he wasn't
c9's first
talented young player so from the very
start
the pressure was on i definitely think
there was some form of pressure
and i just needed to kind of uh get used
to like
playing like in person a lot more like
um
because we're screaming together or
we're playing like land events together
so i just have to get used to the
atmosphere because i've always been
kind of secluded in my room throughout
all those days spent
dumpstering kids online in the comfort
of his bedroom
tens was mostly known for his skills
with the op but
unfortunately for him cloud9 already had
a proven
opera in mixwell tens was left playing
anchor
a role that he wasn't really used to and
every time he got his chance to prove
himself on lan
he kind of choked shot onto marky
as well able to chime in and again for
the player we
are hoping to expect more of and
actually we're expecting more we're not
hoping to we do expect more out of him
he's not really been able to live up to
it so far in the pro league tens face
severe backlash from the counter-strike
community for his lackluster
performances and
almost as quickly as it started his time
on cloud nine was
cut short in october 2019 they benched
him
c9's head coach james earl suggested
it was just a matter of their desired
playstyles clashing
but even after the announcement the cs
community gave tens a hard time
and their harsh words were really
starting to take a toll on his mental
health
i actually got really really depressed
when i noticed everyone was like
saying [ __ ] or mean stuff about me and
uh
that's actually one of the reasons why
like i stopped playing counter-strike
entirely
naturally tens returned to streaming and
content creation after this setback
of course his crispy aim continued to
shine but his fans started to fall in
love with something else
his always easygoing personality he
played like one but
he wasn't a stone-cold killer he was
just a shy weeb who
like most ranked players could never
decide what in-game
settings he wanted to use he was
infectiously relatable
and before long an opportunity presented
itself
that would change tens's life forever
[Music]
and it didn't take long for tens to
realize
he made the right decision his stream
suddenly featured tens of thousands of
new viewers
and he became the first player to hit
valor and rank
on the na server oh
boys let's go
we got valerian finally valerant fit
tens
like a glove it combined the precise
tactical gameplay of counter strike
with creative and unique characters in a
way that makes players like tens
really shine jet one of the game's
flagship agents
might as well have been made for him and
that relationship will be blessing our
timelines
for years to come
he was basically an instant superstar in
a scene that
at the time was only a few months old
tens officially announced that he was
going pro
and valorent for cloud9 in april 2020
and once cloud9 signed some of his
former cs teammates
he was ready to prove himself throughout
the summer he showed that
he was one of valor's most exciting
players to watch
if he would have been my friend but now
immortals after that last one
are you choking me his tongue is really
just pulled
what can they even do they make their
way on site
no 10. and everything tends with an ace
they can just play very passively they
have a lot of sound cues to know that oh
[Music]
the trigger disappeared
beautiful work from tens tens was a
human
highlight reel on cloud nine but they
always seem to
fall short in the end the results just
weren't coming and once the team's igl
shinobi
was removed from the roster things only
got worse
c9 looked even less competitive as the
region's top teams
started to crystallize eventually tens
made a shocking decision he stepped down
from c9's roster
and returned to full-time content
creation
at the start of 2021 so as of right now
i would say
that i'm just going to be doing content
creation until
maybe kobe's up and then i'll kind of
redecide what i want to do when
there's lands and stuff like that when
you consider that he might be the single
best player
in one of the most popular esports in
the world tenza's stream is pretty
unique
he's laid back almost nervous even his
aim lab warmups will wow you like a
parlor trick but
he's so nonchalant about it you can't
look away a 10 stream is several hours
of aim training
osu kilowatt adoration anime breakdowns
pub stomping neurotic chair adjustments
mouse swaps and sensitivity changes
all culminating in some late night
league of legends gameplay
it's never loud always impressive and
often adorable and when tens made his
triumphant return to streaming he pretty
much
picked up where he left off fans poured
in to watch him dumpster
north america's top talent every night
in ranked
but the question remained on everyone's
mind when would he make a return
to pro play he'd alluded to waiting for
lans to return
but cloud9 was simply nowhere near the
top of na at the time
and it was clear to anyone with a twitch
account that tens was
in a league of his own
he's either going a long way around to
the right or he's on the left
oh my god in march
tens got an opportunity but it wasn't
with his old team
instead it was with north america's
number one roster
sentinels whose star player sinatra had
been suspended amidst sexual assault
allegations
from his ex-girlfriend cleo hernandez
sentinels
only had one day to find a replacement
before masters one
and tens was clearly their best option i
don't i think i woke up one day and i
just looked at my twitter dm
and shaz messaged me and said hey you
want to fill in for attorney
i was like okay sentinels managed to
acquire tens on a one-month loan
but nobody knew how he'd match up
against some of the best players in
north america
in competitive play some of them had
grinded the game since launch with their
pro rosters
and for the past couple months tens was
streaming
talking about attack on titan and
playing osu
in q but on march 12th when he hit the
server for sentinels at masters 1
north american valorant would never be
the same
shortly behind that uh is tens he's got
the frenzy
and he's got a kill man all up and moves
his face and he's getting a jumping one
as well on the thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it take down
the remaining member steal
what magic do you have in your hat it's
not going to be enough a flawless round
a statement made sentinel's 200 thieves
with tens on the roster sentinels looked
unstoppable
they only dropped one map on their way
to earning the game's most prestigious
title to date
and with virtually no practice prior to
the event
tens was quick to praise sentinel's igl
shazam
to give credit to shaz think about
if we didn't practice at all for
three days for the entire event we we
played we played two scrims yesterday
and that's the only time we screamed we
didn't scrim
um today we didn't do a warm-up scrim
we didn't scrim uh before the tournament
started
we literally screamed like the daybreak
just two scrims at all
and he was able to explain most stuff
that
um they would do and stuff within like
an hour
and kind of slob me into rule like the
role
um and then he was able to kind of like
counter call against
um lg he was able to get some good reads
against honor thieves he was getting
some good reads
so shaz's igl ability is
insane and while tens was in awe of his
new teammates
the feeling was certainly mutual he's an
insane player
a really good teammate uh he just adds
like so much unpredictability because
like
he doesn't and this is like the most
backhanded compliment i feel like but he
doesn't play like the right way
all the time right but like no great
player does
you know he'll do [ __ ] that i would
never do but he's so
insane that he'll make it work and then
even when he doesn't make it work and
like he gets punished for it
he's a good teammate where he'll admit
that he
you know it didn't work out and he'll
make the good comms and
he's just a person that's impossible to
get mad at even when he makes mistakes
and
i just feel like having that as a
teammate it just brings up like
everybody
there wasn't much time to celebrate
their master's one victory though
tens and sentinels quickly began their
seemingly endless qualification process
for masters 2 right away with the
ultimate goal of qualifying for valorent
champions in december
the game's first global championship
their future was racked with uncertainty
though
despite the success he and his new
roster had enjoyed
tens only had roughly one week left on
his loan
it was now or never if they wanted to
qualify for stage two of challengers
with him but when they ran into built by
gamers
they were in for a shock they're down a
player health bars are low will looking
to spray through the smoke taking some
damage in response bjorn on the flank
finds one
the defuse now being stuck by sam now
he's forced to hop off the kills will
come through and there it is
bbg first across the finish line we'll
see him in the closed qualifiers and
they dethrone the n.a king
kind of depressing in the moment but
that's like damn like
we just lost in the qualifier like it
was a good run guys
uh thanks for invitation man everyone
was shocked and
tense thought he might have played his
final game with sentinels
to his relief sentinels announced a week
later that
tens would be competing with the team
through the end of challenger's finals
and they made sure not to waste their
second shot at challenger's
qualification
defeating every team they faced to earn
a spot where the stakes would be
higher than ever this wasn't just
another qualifier in a sea of online
challenges events
there was a spot in riot's international
land in reykjavik iceland up for grabs
and if there was ever a time for
sentinel's intents to show up
it was now he's looking for something
cheeky could be able to dash on
with that judge but celsius still
playing pivot jumping in
clears up one and around the corner well
it's marshall in its tents
so you don't count it out oh my gosh you
don't count it out and play the retake
game like right now the
oh oh timing's not perfect for zombies
but it doesn't really matter because
tens
is gonna drop everybody with his help
and it's a flawless victory for
sentinels version one not looking like
they have options in some of these
rounds
sentinels dismantled every single
opponent at the north american
challengers finals
to earn their spot in reykjavik as the
region's number one seed
and to top it off cloud9 ceo jackie tien
took to reddit to confirm that a long
agreement was already in place
which would keep tens on sentinel's
roster for masters too
and once tenz and the team arrived in
iceland
they never let their foot off the gas oh
that's a good early defense coming
through from tens and shazam
knocking down everybody here for fnatic
very little left to work with
time is against him here as well shazam
he doesn't stop another one for him
can do to maybe get a couple kills there
could keep some damage there but shazam
finishes it off with style lovely stuff
there's a lot of work on his hands here
he's not going to be able to deal any
damage it's up to dapper there
oh
the hell was that from dapper sentinels
were pretty quick to derail the eu hype
train and
they had a blast doing it but most
importantly the team was bonding
outside of the server iceland provided
tens with an opportunity to finally meet
his teammates
in person and it didn't take long for
everyone to warm up to him
especially dapper yeah tyson tyson's
like a little
like a little kid dude he's he's like a
little golden retriever you know like a
little puppy
so i like talking to him i like hanging
out with him and
you know he's cool we all went to lagoon
but me and tyson
stayed back and like went for longer
like a couple hours more
so you know we kicked it and he was cool
sentinels just
kept winning as the tournament went on
defeating vikings a new turn
to earn a spot in the grand final versus
a fanatic team they'd already sent to
the losers bracket
tanz and his team had still yet to lose
a single map and when he hit the server
in the finals
he popped off omen for them but zombies
up close and personal inspector running
out of bullets though and the trades
keep on coming through fnatic still with
a chance here
but tens is making it impossible
fantastic
finish from him the spike is already
being defused hit
by fnatic tends to able to find the
headshot onto derka
the pressure is coming through though
still a form that spike
keeps getting restarted on the defuse
doma has to stick it for tens
nails doma with that marshall at
distance but they don't have a read on
where
any of the fanatic players are yet
sentinels go in completely dry thinking
they can walk it through and pens has to
do a bunch of work to bring this one
back
into sentinel's favor someone's close
they don't know oh my god he gets less
the team flash
the team flash magnum's in the smoke
here oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels
they're gonna get the defuse they've
done it sentinels are the masters to
reykjavik champions and they do it
flawlessly they didn't drop a single map
they have made history here because they
are the first
global champions in valor and history
sentinels claimed valorent's first major
lan after a close series
and tens topped the entire lobby with
the highest average combat score
to earn himself the title of grand
finals mvp
sentinels were quite literally on top of
the world
they went undefeated in their
championship run and to tens
finally proving himself on lan meant
everything but
even after winning his future with the
team was still uncertain
hence you weren't even on this team a
few months ago man what
now you're a land champion you're the
world's best
how are you feeling um always
like i feel wonderful this team is
amazing and i feel right at home with
them and
hopefully i can continue playing with
them because this is the best team i've
ever played on
i mean obviously it would be a
no-brainer that i'd want to compete with
this team
like this team is honestly so amazing i
have fun with them i can trust all of
them
they're i don't know they're just the
best team that's ever had and
really like i would stay
if i could and i really hope i could so
i'm praying
but shortly after sentinels finished
celebrating their international title
tenza's prayers were answered you just
found out that uh you're joining the
sentinels full time
tell me i feel about it it's amazing
i'm gonna loss of words that's that's
double good things
happened today we won and then i want
sandals
tens is now a permanent member of the
undisputed best team in the world
and they're showing no signs of slowing
down sentinel's win in iceland
even earned them enough circuit points
to qualify for champions at the end of
the year
but with the meta drastically changing
going into masters 3 and berlin
it's up to them to make sure that they
can stay ahead of the curve
and continue their reign but with tens
on their side
anything seems possible
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages